[موسيقى]
مقطع من اغنيه الجهر الفار لمغني الراب
الايراني توماس الصالحين
في الاحتجاجات الاخيره
بالقرب من ميدان الحريه
بعد وفاه الشاب
الاغاني الاحتجاجيه يحتاج اليها المجتمع
لانها تعطيك بعض الحماسه وعاده في مثل هذه
اللحظات قد لا استمعوا للانماط الموسيقيه
الاخرى
الموسيقى الاحتجاجيه الاهم فيها هو
الاحساس الذي تنقله اليك وتاثيرها عليك
ويمكن ان تسمعها في انماط الموسيقيه
مختلفه هنا صوت تخرج في مسابقه المواهب في
ايران
في زمن الاحتجاجات الاخيره
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فلهجت بها السن المحتجين وتردد صداها حتى
في الاماكن العامه
[موسيقى]
والموسيقى الاحتجاجات يقول استاذ الموسيقى
محمد هماتي انها والده اللحظه وقد تكسب
شعبيتها اذا تناغمت مع مطالب المحتجين
الموسيقى الاحتجاجيه في ايران كانت قبل
ثوره الدستور بدايه القرن الماضي وكان
الموسيقيون يلجاون اليها للمطالبه
بالعداله وبالحقوق المدنيه وهي نوع من
الاحتجاج السلمي من دون ايجاد اي توتر في
المجتمع
اغنيه يبدو ان زمانها لم ينتهي بعد رددها
عمال حقول الارز في ايطاليا احتجاجا على
اوضعهم القاسيه خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
للوضع عن نظيرتها الايطاليه
عن واقعهم
عند الاحتجاجيه بالموسيقى خد لا تكون في
الكثير من الاوقات المقامات الموسيقيه
مهمه ولا حتى نوع الموسيقى فالكلمات
والشعارات قد تتقدم على قوانين الموسيقى
وانماطها فالهدف ان تصل الرساله الى من
يعنيه الامر
نوردين تغيير الجزيره